>>> HOW IS THIS FOR A FIRST
MESSAGE FROM YOUR NEW BOSS.
A STAFF WIDE EMAIL, ELON MUSK
SUGGESTING THE COMPANY COULD GO
INTO BANKRUPTCY AS EXECUTIVES
ARE RESIGNING, ADVERTISERS ARE
FLEEING AND TROLLS ARE RUNNING
RAMPANT ON THE PLATFORM SINCE HE
TOOK OVER.
WE HAVE RAHEL HERE WITH US FOR
MORE.
FUL ON-- I FEEL IT'S THE LAST 1
HOURS THAT ARE THE MOST CHAOS.
>> A RECENTLY LAIDOFF EMPLOYEE
TOLD CNN, IT WAS LIKE THE
TITANIC WITH EVERYONE LOOKING
FOR LIFEBOATS.
THE HEAD OF TRUST AND SAFETY,
CHIEF INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER, CHIEF PRIVACY OFFICER,
JUST SOME OF THE RECENT
RESIGNATIONS.
IT COMES AFTER A LEGAL TEAM
WARNED IN AN INTERNAL COUPLE
MESSAGE THAT MUSK'S PRIORITY IS
RECOUPING THE LOSSES HE'S
INCURRING AS A RESULT OF FAILING
TO GET OUT OF BUYING TWITTER.
SO IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO LURE
SKEPTICAL ADVERTISERS.
ALSO NOT HELPING AN EXPLOSION OF
TROLLS AND OTHERS CREATING
IMPOSTER ACCOUNTS AFTER MUSK
BLEW UP VERIFICATION ON TWITTER.
YOU CAN SEE SOMEONE BEING A FAKE
DONALD TRUMP ACCOUNT.
AND TWITTER ALSO GAVE A CHECK
MARK TO JESUS CHRIST.
THINGS ARE GETTING CONFUSION --
HE HAS RISEN.
>> HOW DO YOU AUTHENTICATE THAT.
>> THAT WAS A MOMENT --
>> HOLD ON A SECOND.
>> BEING FAIR, I STOLE THAT FROM
DONIE O'SULLIVAN'S TWITTER.
>> HOW DO YOU VERIFY THAT.
>> IT WAS THE COMEDIC TIMING.
DON'T SELL YOURSELF SHORT.
>> BUT IT IS CHAOTIC AS KAITLAN
POINTED OUT.
HIS FIRST ALL STAFF EMAIL,
IMAGINE THIS THE FIRST EMAIL
FROM YOUR BOSS, HE ANNOUNCED A
MANDATORY RETURN TO OFFICE AND
WARNED THE ECONOMIC PICTURE
AHEAD IS DIRE AND WITHOUT
SUBSCRIPTION REVENUE THERE'S A
CHANCE TWITTER WILL NOT SURVIVE
THE UPCOMING DOWNTURN.
BUT THROUGH IT ALL HE'S
CONTINUED TO TWEET AND HARD TO
SAY IF THINGS WILL STABILIZE,
JUST A DAY AGO HE TWEETED PLEASE
NOTE TWITTER WILL DO LOTS OF
DUMB THINGS, HE SAID IT, DUMB
THINGS IN COMING MONTHS.
WE'LL KEEP WHAT WORKS AND CHANGE
WHAT DOESN'T.
>> I SIGNED UP FOR HIS TWEET
ALERTS SO NOW I KNOW WHEN ELON
MUSK TWEETS BECAUSE I'M
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHAT HE
SAYS ABOUT IT.
>> YOU MISS A LITTLE YOU MISS A
LOT WITH ELON.
>>> THE TURMOIL AT TWITTER IS
MOUNTING BY THE HOUR.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT JUST
SUSPENDED ITS HIGHLY TOUTED PAID
VERIFICATION SYSTEM TALKED SO
MUCH ABOUT.
EXECUTIVES ARE QUITTING AND
ADVISERS ARE BOLTING AND
REMAINING EMPLOYEES ARE FACING
NEW THREATS FROM THEIR NEW
LEADER, ELON MUSK.
CNN'S OLIVER DARCY JOINS ME WITH
MORE.
OLIVER, DO PEOPLE BELIEVE WE ARE
WATCHING TWITTER'S COLLAPSE
RIGHT NOW?
>> Reporter: YEAH, KATE, I THINK
THAT'S THE REAL QUESTION.
CAN TWITTER SURVIVE ELON MUSK?
AND THE REAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT GIVEN THE CHAOS THAT'S
CONSUMED THIS COMPANY OVER THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS SINCE HE TOOK
OVER.
THE LATEST EXAMPLE, OF COURSE,
BEING THAT SUSPENSION OF THE
TWITTER BLUE FEATURE THAT MUSK
HAD HYPED AND ROLLED OUT IN A
CHAOTIC FASHION, BUT I JUST WANT
TO WALK PEOPLE THROUGH HA HAS
HAPPENED EXACTLY OVER THE PAST
TWO WEEKS SINCE MUSK TOOK OVER.
YOU'VE SEEN TOP EXECUTIVES FLEE
THE COMPANY OR BEEN OUSTED FROM
THE COMPANY INCLUDING AS OF
YESTERDAY THE HEAD OF TRUST AND
SAFETY WHO IS A REALLY KEY
INTEGRAL PERSON AND SEEN
ADVERTISERS FLEE THE COMPANY
BECAUSE THEY ARE NO LONGER
ESSENTIALLY TRUSTING THAT
TWITTER IS NOT GOING TO PUT
THEIR CONTENT NEXT TO HATE
SPEECH, MISINFORMATION, THINGS
LIKE THAT.
YOU'VE SEEN EMPLOYEE MORALE TANK
AFTER THEY LAID OFF HALF OF THE
COMPANY.
I WAS TALKING TO AN EX-TWITTER
EMPLOYEE YESTERDAY WHO COMPARED
IT TO THE "TITANIC" WITH
EMPLOYEES LOOKING FOR A WAY OUT.
LOOKING FOR A LIFEBOAT AND
YOU'VE SEEN THE FTC WARN TWITTER
THEY NEED TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS AND SO
THIS WHOLE COMPANY IS FACING
MOUNTING PROBLEMS AND ELON MUSK
IN THE MEANTIME, IS SORT OF JUST
TWEETING THROUGH IT.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
IS, KATE.